it was an amazing series that it's a
famous documentary maker called Paul
Watson who I was fresh out of film
school and he'd say put that shot next
to that shot and you've really got
something I see yeah but that was two
different days and he would look at me
and you can go Simon you want the truth
or a good film and whenever I said I
want both he went sorry you can't do
that people have come up to you and go
you lost what are you doing mr. bean
what you doing and I'd say yeah I'm
completely lost and they would take me
through all these narrow streets and on
the way I talk to them and we'd sit down
have a cup of tea I know everyone would
gather round and I'd ask them questions
about what's the story if I gave you a
camera which is something I ask people
quite a lot if I gave you a camera what
would you point it out you have a
responsibility to the fact to the
situation with 127 hours which is the
story of a man who gets trapped in a
canyon on his own and a boulder falls on
his arm and traps it and after five days
he cuts it off with a multi-tool in a
rather spectacular fashion and he's very
much alive very much involved in the
film and I had a responsibility to the
facts of his story
you have to hang out with the people I
think because then it's brilliant
because they will come up with the most
wonderful ways of phrasing things I
loved being in Bombay because they flip
between English and Hindi in this
wonderful way and all sorts of rather
archaic British expressions the died
away here will pop up in the midst of
sentences their narrative is a very
seductive thing storytelling is very
seductive and it will take over it
always does and it has to that's the
point but yet that story will always
come first it will always push its way
to the front as it should that's that's
the job of the story
you